I'm with death who's going to tell you
something you might not know about
origami Jeff take it away I'd like to
tell you about a piece of origami that's
in space now space satellites they have
solar panels and solar panels need to
unfold and you might imagine a piece of
paper slowly unfolding unfortunately to
unfold most solar panels you need two
motors want to pull it this way and want
to pull it up this way but Japanese
actually physicists realized that you
could probably do it in one motor
instead and what you came up with was
this you could take a solar panel and
unfold it with one motor all the way out
knowing that you can also fold it all
the way back in how this actually works
is you fold the piece of paper into fits
like so mentally I am making it look
easy
and then what you do is you fold it over
repeatedly almost making a snake all the
way up such that there's a little bit of
an angle all the way up but what this
means is this piece of paper you can
fold down far more compactly and far
more quickly then your traditional
folding now this actual force called the
mirror fault and it's also used outside
of solar panels it's actually been
recently tested with lithium ion
batteries because it folds down so
compactly it improves the energy density
but that's not the reason why I love
this not because it's gone into space
but because it works so well for maps
you can take a map out of your pocket
instantly unfold it see exactly where
you are and instantly fold it back up
again and no other fault I know for maps
can do this thing so despite being an
amazing piece of origami that it's gone
into space it's actually the most useful
piece of origami I know down here on
earth